[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Souleymane Bachir Diagne est-ce que vous
diriez aujourd'hui que la démocratie en
Afrique est plutôt en train de reculer
malheureusement c'est un constat à faire
l'Afrique semble avoir renouée par
exemple avec les coups d'État c'est
vraiment la meilleure manifestation
possible de se recule démocratique
en revanche il fut un temps où lorsqu'il
y avait un coup d'état quelque part
le club des présidents africains
accueillait le nouveau venu et au fond
s'accommoder parfaitement du fait
accompli d'accord ce n'est plus le cas
c'est plus le cas aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus le cas aujourd'hui voilà ça veut
dire que la démocratie a reculé mais il
est encore
la boussole l'orientation générale de du
continent alors par exemple quand il y a
eu le coup d'État au Mali ou au Burkina
Faso il y a eu des réactions
ce qu'on appelle la sous-région
c'est-à-dire l'Afrique de l'Ouest oui
voilà le président qui ont manifesté
leur désaccord avec ce qui se passait
absolument la CEDEAO
cette organisation de des États de
l'Afrique de l'Ouest c'est réuni a
condamné le coup d'État à demander à la
jointe qui s'était mise en place de
donner très rapidement des délais de
fixer des délais pour retourner à
l'ordre constitutionnel et donc voilà le
genre de réaction qui montre qu'en
définitive
l'exigence est toujours celle-là c'est
l'exigence de démocratie est-ce qu'il y
a une exigence la croyance sur la
démocratie ça existe encore ça existe il
faut que c'est un peu remise en question
pas uniquement en Afrique d'ailleurs oui
on le voit ailleurs c'est vrai la
démocratie a reculé partout dans le
monde quoi que cette organisme qui
s'appelle veilledem qui est un organisme
de réflexion qui prend la mesure de la
démocratie et qui publie des rapports
annuels a bien constaté que la
démocratie avait reculé partout dans le
monde partout dans le monde
2 tiers de l'humanité vivent sous des
régimes qui ne sont pas des régimes
démocratiques c'est énorme c'était
normal
et ensuite les régimes autoritaires ne
sont pas sur la défensive il y a
l'affirmation qu'au fond du côté du
sillon juge des choses par leur
efficacité que l'efficacité serait
plutôt du côté de ces régimes
autoritaires et donc ceci est assez
alarmant ce qui alarmant également
c'est que les jeunes ne semblent plus
adhérer à cette valeur de la démocratie
autrement dit ce qui est plus inquiétant
que les coups d'État eux-mêmes c'est que
des jeunes manifestent pour saluer ses
coups d'État et puis manifeste avec des
drapeaux qui sont ceux d'un pays dont on
peut pas dire qu'ils soient
véritablement un pays démocratique et
cela est inquiétant et ça c'est
inquiétant pour l'avenir non c'est
inquiétant pour l'avenir parce que si
nous parlons de la jeunesse de jeunesse
africaine en particulier nous parlons
effectivement de l'avenir de ce
continent quels sont les les causes et
les fautifs c'est des responsabilités
locales ou est-ce que il y a aussi des
responsabilités exogènes étrangères je
parle pour le continent africain
évidemment oui alors il faut voir une
cause massive pour au moins deux des
coups d'État
que nous avons à l'esprit vous et moi
c'est-à-dire le Mali et le Burkina Faso
une cause massive qui est l'insécurité
dans le Sahel oui le terrorisme le
djihadisme aujourd'hui dans le Sahel le
Mali a failli basculer à un moment donné
il y a eu intervention de l'armée
française comme nous le savons le
Burkina se trouve aussi sous la menace
de terroristes
l'État au burkinabè et l'État malien le
contrôle plus une grande partie de leur
territoire et les coups d'État ont été
d'abord des réponses à cette situation
d'accord l'insécurité et donc voilà une
cause massive donc il faut tenir compte
et qui explique un peu le basculement de
ces pays dans des dans des régimes
autoritaires
maintenant le le
l'idée que selon laquelle les jeunes au
fond ne donne plus tellement de valeur à
la démocratie alors que ça a été la
grande conquête de la fin des années 90
lorsque le continent africain conduisait
oublier de la démocratie et des droits
de l'homme a connu des transitions
démocratiques a connu des des
changements des alternances et c'est ça
c'est le meilleur signe qu'on ne pouvoir
en place perd les élections et que le
Président de la République appelle son
opposant bravo tu as gagné viens qu'on
s'occupe de la transition c'est la
meilleure c'est le meilleur signe bien
sûr de la démocratie en revanche la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons maintenant c'est une situation
où on dit la démocratie ça ne se mange
pas la Russie est répétée souvent et
donc l'idée derrière une phrase comme
celle-là c'est que la démocratie aurait
échoué à assurer le développement à
donner des emplois à faire sortir de la
pauvreté
et il est difficile de rappeler une
chose c'est que ça n'était pas la
fonction de la démocratie de donner à
manger la fonction de la démocratie
c'était d'ouvrir des possibles de
permettre que les valeurs humaines et
tous les talents s'expriment librement
et c'est de cela qu'il s'agit maintenant
il s'agit de convaincre de cela et donc
il y a un travail d'éducation à la
démocratie qu'il faut mener c'est la
meilleure réponse qu'on puisse opposer à
ce scepticisme démocratique comme on
pourrait l'appeler alors Souley vous
êtes sénégalais et le Sénégal
ça fait figure un peu de contre-exemple
justement
ou plutôt de bon exemple puisque le
Sénégal est né démocratie tripartite au
début 1974 avec le président Senghor
après ça c'est encore ouvert encore
davantage il y a une alternance qui se
fait même si il y a beaucoup de chahuts
beaucoup de bruit deux alternances
comment vous l'expliquez pourquoi ou
c'est légal ça a marché mieux
qu'ailleurs oui il faut déjà
le mot exception semble un petit peu
excessif excessif mais il faut
l'utiliser parce qu'il faut se rappeler
une chose c'est que le Sénégal a une
tradition démocratique qui vient d'un
corps plus loin
rappelons-nous que le Sénégal était une
colonie particulière pendant la
colonisation puisque c'était une colonie
qui où il y avait quatre villes qui
étaient des villes de des communes de
plein exercice comme on a plus là
c'est-à-dire que les habitants des
villes de Saint-Louis de dak
était non pas des sujets français mais
des citoyens français et ils envoyaient
d'ailleurs des cahiers de doléances
envoyer des cahiers de doléances aux
États généraux et qui ont voté et envoyé
des députés au Parlement français depuis
le 19e siècle c'est ainsi que plaisir
gagne Lamine gay
doudouf ont été des députés sénégalais
envoyés au Parlement français et donc le
Sénégal connaît des élections depuis le
19e siècle une culture de il y a une
culture de l'élection de l'élection
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
lorsque Senghor a imitant ce qui se
passait dans le dans le sur le continent
a instauré le parti unique il n'a jamais
voulu l'appeler parti unique il a
toujours dit non non c'est un parti
unifié il y a unifié des tendances qui a
rassemblé des parties différentes ça
veut dire qu'il y avait une sorte de
gêne devant la notion même de partie
unique de la part de Senghor pour deux
raisons d'abord c'est un homme de la
quatrième République il a toujours connu
la démocratie deuxièmement le meilleur
frein à l'autoritarisme c'était 5 ans
lui-même poète philosophe il s'est
interdit au fond de partir en laissant
un pays qui aurait été qui aurait été un
pays autoritaire sous le régime d'un
seul parti donc il a instauré ce
multipartisme donc
c'est la tradition politique
à côté de cela il faut regarder
également un caractère particulier du
Sénégal qui est la force des confrérie
religieuses les leaders des guides
spirituels de ces confrérie ont toujours
également veiller à la paix sociale
l'un d'eux à comparer le rôle des
marabouts à celui des pompiers d'accord
disons qu'ils sont toujours là pour
éteindre les incendies pour opérer des
ardeurs
assurer qu'il y a une paix sociale et
l'un dans l'autre tout cela ét
[Musique]
[Rires]
la promotion de la négritude mais la
négritude c'est pour lui c'est justement
une affirmation mais une affirmation qui
ne nie pas les différences et tout ça on
a le sentiment que il y a une remise en
question chez les jeunes aujourd'hui de
justement toute cette
philosophie et qui dit mais finalement
s'en gore c'était pas mettez
l'expression
un peu un collaborateur de de du colon
quoi
vous êtes d'accord avec ça alors c'est
vrai que c'est une figure très
controversée de ce point de vue là il
faut rappeler et vous allez bien fait de
le dire que tout en étant avec Aimé
Césaire et Léon Gontran Damas un des
pionniers de la négritude de
l'affirmation des valeurs de
civilisation du monde noir ainsi qu'il
définissait la négritude il est d'abord
et avant tout un philosophe du métissage
de la rencontre et du dialogues de
culture et ceci était très important au
fond une des affirmations les plus
importantes chez c'est que chacun doit
être métisse à sa façon elle doit être
métisse le doigt est important parce que
c'est un devoir éthique c'est une
disposition éthique à au décentrement à
la capacité de regarder la perspective
de l'autre etc et ceci a défini la
personnalité de symbole et a défini
également pendant très longtemps la
philosophie politique sur laquelle le
Sénégal a reposé en effet Senghor a
toujours estimé qu'au bout du compte
dans un monde d'interdépendance il
s'agissait de développer dans la paix
dans la capacité de négociation et dans
le dialogue un pouvoir de négociation de
plus en plus importante c'est un
gradualiste sur beaucoup de choses
d'accord il croyait énormément également
en unité africaine et il estimait que
ceci se réaliseraient graduellement par
certains concentrique et au fond cette
philosophie là qui a été la philosophie
sur laquelle Sénégal a été fondée et
vous l'avez dit aujourd'hui remise en
cause par une jeunesse qui est peut-être
plus impatiente qui est plus
bouillante d'une certaine façon cultive
la cancelle culture aussi ce qu'on
appelle la philosophie walk c'est à dire
que le rejet de voilà qui épouse qui
épouse qui épouse une philosophie de la
rupture et évidemment 5h semble être aux
antipodes de cette philosophie de la
rupture ça ça
point de vue là c'est quelqu'un qui
appelait à un dialogue d'études il a
même écrit que le le
colonialisme était un mâle mais que dans
la mesure où c'était un fait accompli il
fallait en quelque sorte profiter du
fait que le signe le colonialisme avait
rapproché les peuples et avait constitué
une sorte de d'embryon de cosmopolitisme
et vous voyez donc cette manière qui
était la sienne de regarder la totalité
c'est un penseur de la totalité c'est
pas en penseur de son propre
particularisme et quand on y penseur de
la totalité évidemment on a le sentiment
que le temps travaille pour aller dans
la bonne direction et qu'il ne faut pas
avoir ses sortes d'impatients et c'est
ce caractère révolutionnaire ce n'était
pas la révolutionnaire il était réformes
et estimait que les réformes étaient
ceux qui transformaient graduellement et
de manière apaisée les sociétés alors je
voudrais vous faire réagir à deux
phrases puisque vous êtes un brillante
exégète
une phrase qui a fait couler énormément
d'encre quand il dit que l'émotion est
et que la raison est Hélène grec
en fait
c'est terrible comme comme c'est une
phrase qui lui a été et le moment
c'est une phrase qu'il a écrite dans un
de ses tous premiers articles qui
s'appelle ce que l'homme noir apporte
donc c'est cette phrase ne lieu pas
simplement attribué elle est de lui
simplement elle n'a pas été comprise
Senghor n'a pas arrêté de répéter qu'il
était bergsonien avant tout la première
chose à faire c'était de voir la
signification qu'il donnait à ce concept
d'émotion et quand on sait que Bergson a
fait une distinction entre ce qu'il a
appelé l'émotion créatrice c'est à dire
la capacité que nous avons d'être ému et
au sens étymologique de émotion eu un
mouvement de sortie de soi pour créer
Senghor est un philosophe de l'art avant
tout
sortir de soi pour créer c'est la
signification de l'émotion créatrice et
à cette émotion créatrice donc que
personne appelait une émotion supra
intellectuelle personne opposé ce qu'il
appelait une émotion infra
intellectuelle qui était la simple
réaction quelque chose se passe et j'ai
une réaction émotive vis-à-vis de cette
chose là une fois que l'on a rappelé
l'origine de ce mot de ce concept
d'émotion et l'usage qu'on fait Senghor
cette phrase apparaît pour ce qu'elle
est la capacité créatrice de l'émotion
et
aux oeuvres artistiques africaines ce
que l'approche rationnelle d'imitation
de la nature est à la statuette ça
devient une analogie tout à fait
compréhensible dès lors qu'on en a fait
l'exégèse c'est-à-dire qu'on a reconduit
les concepts utilisés par Senghor à leur
origine
alors la deuxième citation qui est
magnifique magnifique l'orgueil d'être
différent n'empêche pas le bonheur
d'être ensemble voilà ça c'est fabuleux
et absolument il devrait renseigner ça
partout ça mais oui s'il y avait une
formule à retenir de senghorse cela
devrait être celle-là mesurer dit-il
plus exactement mesure l'orgueil de ces
différents au bonheur d'être ensemble et
donc affirmer sa propre différence
affirmer que le monde est plus réel que
le monde n'est pas uniforme qu'il est
tissé de toute nos différences des
différentes manières que les cultures
ont d'exprimer l'aventure humaine chaque
culture donne un visage particulier à
l'humanité et ses visages ensemble
composent la symphonie du monde d'une
certaine façon pour parler le langage de
l'art et le langage de la musique et
bien cette phrase là résume Senghor elle
est encore mieux veut que le couple
enracinement ouverture qui l'emploie
aussi à peu près avec la même
signification mesurer l'orgueil d'être
différent s'affirmer défendre illustrer
le visage que l'on offre de l'humanité
mais en même temps se souvenir qu'il
faut que nous soyons tous ensemble que
nous nous donnions un horizon
d'universalité un horizon qui repose sur
notre humanité partagée et que cela est
la tâche et ce message singolien
s'adresse à nous aujourd'hui alors
justement vous parliez tout à l'heure de
l'exemple sénégalais sur à propos de
l'islam en disant que c'était un islam
avec des repères les Tidjanes les
morilles et d'autres confréris qui
permettent la tempérance on a le
sentiment et vous avez beaucoup écrit
là-dessus sur l'enfermement
religieux l'enfermement nationaliste
est-ce que d'une certaine façon
aujourd'hui on n'est pas dans ce monde
là justement et dans ce monde
d'enfermement et que d'une de façon
alors je vous titille ce que vous êtes
musulman est-ce que l'Islam ne participe
pas particulièrement à ça vous avez
raison l'islamisme quand on regarde le
monde qui est le notre aujourd'hui c'est
un monde extrêmement fragmenté fracturé
même ou les la politique ressemble à du
tribalyse aujourd'hui on est dans un
monde qui a pu prononcer cette phrase
exceptionnelle de fait alternatif comme
si au fond rien n'était un fait si ce
n'était pas accepté comme tel par ma
propre tribu politique la vérité dépend
de la tribu politique qui qui énonce la
proposition en question et d'ailleurs
ceci n'est pas son lien avec ce que nous
avions dit du recul démocratique le
recul démocratique et la fragmentation
le caractère fracturé de nos de nos
engagements politiques et le tribalisme
en politique tout cela va ensemble alors
dans ce monde où des
identités où on a l'impression que nous
n'avons plus un espace public commun où
nous échangeons des arguments
malheureuses mais oui mais oui il a pas
fait mal raison parce que nous pouvons
au fond et c'est la nature même de
l'espace public nous pouvons différer ne
pas être d'accord en parlant la même
langue et en échangeant des arguments en
comprenant que nous partageons au moins
les mêmes faits et que nous avons nous
entretenons nous avons la même logique
les identités empêchent même cela il n'y
a plus d'espace public si tout ce que je
fais c'est faire la performance de ma
propre identité répéter que mon
expérience et celle d'un homme noir et
que vous ne pouvez pas la comprendre
parce que vous n'êtes pas un homme noir
etc ça veut dire que tout argument à ce
moment-là est réduit à sa plus simple
expression tout argument devient un
argument abdominem ce qu'on appelle de
l'essentialisme et de l'essentialisme je
dis ce que je dis parce que je suis qui
je suis vous dites ce que vous dites ce
que vous êtes qui vous êtes et au fond
nous avons les discours parallèles qui
vont être qui vont nourrir cette
tribalisme là et malheureusement dans
ces affirmations de l'identité dans ses
enfermements identitaires la religion et
la chose la plus facile à mobiliser des
moteurs un des moteurs et la religion
est précisément ce pourquoi on est prêt
à mourir et donc vous avez raison de
dire que les religions de ce point de
vue là en général peuvent jouer un rôle
de d'amplification de ce tribalisme de
ses identitalises de ces enfermements
dans des particularismes et
malheureusement nous avons vu cela avec
les interprétations les plus extrémistes
de de l'islam ceci fait partie de notre
géopolitique aujourd'hui et donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle il faut et c'est
une un travail que moi-même et d'autres
essayons de mener évidemment et c'est un
travail qui a un rôle d'intellectuel ça
rôle intellectuel rappeler des inter
ce qui nous ramène au cas sénégalais
dont nous parlions tout à l'heure c'est
confrérie elles sont
autant d'expression du soufisme lequel
soufisme est précisément
l'interprétation la plus ouverte la plus
apaisée il a plus apaisée de l'Islam et
la plus réaliste le sophisme en son
essence même et acceptation
nécessairement de la différence et donc
plus réalise et le plus réalisme c'est
véritablement la signification du de la
tolérance quelque part dans vos écrits
j'ai retenu cette phrase que vous vous
prêchez pardon c'est un peu facile pour
une reconstruction de la pensée
religieuse oui sous l'influence d'un
auteur qui qui m'a beaucoup marqué
auquel j'ai consacré un livre qui est le
philosophe indien le penseur indien
poète lui-même Mohamed alors qui est
très critiquée par un autre écrivain
papa pas par un penseur mais un écrivain
qui est aussi d'origine
qui s'appelle viessnable il estime que
Ikbal est pas du tout une référence à
conseiller qu'on voit de Népal à droite
là qui est un très très grand écrivain
et Mohamed
Ikbal qui est pakistanais je crois de
spirituel du Pakistan parce que il a
affirmé un moment donné c'est dans un de
ses écrits qui le fallait penser une
autonomie au sein du sous-continent
indien des régions à majorité musulmane
ça explique probablement la raison pour
laquelle une épaule ne tient pas en
grande estime mais cela étant si nous
regardons la philosophie de de Mohamed
tel qu'elle s'exprime à la fois dans ses
écrits théoriques également dans sa
poésie il a exprimé le meilleur du
soufisme l'idée précisément il a dit il
a écrit contre ce qu'il a appelé je le
cite l'idole de la race et de la tribu
et c'est en cette formule par exemple
que l'on peut voir
l'interprétation de la lecture qu'il a
fait de l'islam qui serait un islam du
pluralisme et de l'ouverture et de la
même manière il a également estimé que
l'islam avait eu une phase de
pétrification après une phase
d'ouverture d'inventivité de créativité
où on a vu pour parler le langage de Mao
zedom sans école s'épanouir autant
d'école juridique il y a eu un moment de
pétrification
inutile de la pensée islamique c'est la
raison pour laquelle il a son ouvrage
majeur en prose c'est intitulé
reconstruire la pensée religieuse de
l'islam on dit souvent aujourd'hui que
l'Afrique un peu facilement comme ça et
le continent du 21e siècle vous êtes
d'accord avec ça ou vous trouvez ce sont
des formules qui veulent pas dire
grand-chose
il y a de la formule évidemment là
dedans mais il y a une réalité qui est
d'abord une réalité démographique les
prospectives se disent que la
démographie c'est un destin ça veut dire
ce qu'il faut en tenir compte d'accord
quand on regarde la démocratie
aujourd'hui dans le monde c'est vrai que
l'Afrique va avoir une démographie les
plus importantes et des plus jeunes dans
de génération dans Demain d'accord
finalement et ceci est le premier à tout
et le premier élément mais ça peut être
un handicap aussi ça peut être handicap
2 milliards d'individus 2050 aujourd'hui
le fait que l'Afrique est la démographie
que ce continent a ça signifie autant de
jeunes qu'il faut pouvoir
porter qu'il faut pouvoir nourrir qu'il
faut pouvoir inscrire
former à qui il faut donner des emplois
et c'est un casse-tête énorme mais la
même démographie qui est un problème est
un atout également dès que l'on regarde
les tendances et qu'on regarde la
prospective d'autant d'autant que c'est
un continent qui a des ressources
énormes des ressources très importantes
et donc une Afrique qui prend
aujourd'hui conscience de sa propre
force et qui affirme sa présence dans le
monde il n'y a il n'y a peu on disait
que l'Afrique ne pesait que moins de 2%
du commerce mondial au fond que le
continent pouvait disparaître corps et
bien dans l'Atlantique
[Musique]
à l'humanité mais que sur le plan des
échanges aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le
cas une personne ne le dit et c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs il y a
une nouvelle rue vers l'Afrique après la
ruée des colonisations maintenant c'est
la rue du partenariat des pays
s'intéressent à l'Afrique et il y a une
concurrence des des des fêtes aux
anciennes puissances coloniales qui
étaient qui pensait être établie sur le
terrain africain et qui s'avère que ce
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui et donc
effectivement il y a des raisons
objectives de dire que c'est un
continent d'avenir alors de là à dire
que le 21e siècle lui appartiendra là on
retrouve la formule
merci Souleymane Bachir Ndiaye merci
beaucoup de cette entretien merci de
votre accueil
[Musique]